Support for Think Fast Talk Smart
the podcast comes in part
from stanford continuing studies.
Stanford Continuing Studies is
offering more than 140 online courses
this spring to enhance your personal and
professional life.
Choose from courses in business,
leadership, communication,
tech in data science and many more.
Think fast talk smart list for
a 15% tuition disc 15 when
using the code think 15.
This promotion is available for
the spring quarter only.
Registration is now open.
Classes begin soon, learn more at
continuing studies.stanford.edu.
[MUSIC]
>> Way back in graduate school,
I had an amazing internship
at George Lucas's Lucasfilm.
The CEO at the time once talked to us
about how hard it was to reliably and
predictably be creative.
These concepts are often
antithetical to each other and
they apply across different industries.
Today we will explore how design
thinking can help with this challenge.
I'm Matt Abrahams and
I teach Strategic Communication at
Stanford Graduate School of Business.
Welcome to Think Fast,
Talk Smart, the podcast.
I am super excited today to speak
with Sarah Stein Greenberg,
who is the Executive Director of
the Hosho Plattner Institute of Design at
Stanford University,
known more simply as the D school.
While leading this incredibly talented and
creative organization,
Sarah found time to author an awesome book
called creative acts for curious people.
How to think, create and
lead in unconventional ways.
Welcome, Sarah.
Thanks for joining me.
I am so excited for
our conversation today.
>> Matt thank you so much I'm excited to
be here and if you could see my face right
now you'd have a huge smile on it because
I'm very excited for our conversation.
>> Well I've got a big smile too,
so let's get started.
The D school is all about
helping students and
executives learn design thinking skills
>> For
those who aren't familiar with design
thinking, can you define what it is?
And how it can help us personally
as well as professionally?
>> I'm happy to start there.
So many people have this idea of design,
that is really about the kind
of visual aspects of the world around
us like the aesthetic qualities, or
maybe the way that your room feels after
you rearrange the furniture, right?
And those are definitely aspects of
design and design has through its long
history really been kind of poking its
nose into lots of different places.
And what I mean by that is, those same
ways that you can think about being
intentional about what your room feels
like or how your phone is designed,
the way in which you know a glass
fits in your hand perfectly.
Those same ideas can
actually be extrapolated and
used to design experiences and
services and even systems.
And so we're in an era now where
design is being used not just for
all of those aesthetic purposes, but also
to think about what should be created.
How do we actually deliver
services that are better for
the people who are accessing them or
less expensive?
Thinking about how do we actually
like redesign a complex system?.
For example, one of our fellows a few
years ago was working on redesigning
the way in which substitute teaching
happens in the United States, like really
interesting, complex multivariable
kinds of projects and problems.
And so design thinking is kind of
the vocabulary that sits underneath that,
right?
It's a way that people who may
have a formal design training or
may come from lots of different
disciplines can start to use the same sets
of practices both the skills and
the mindsets of design to improve those
services, improve those products.
And even think really creatively about
like what the future of your business
could look like or how you might
tackle a large social system.
>> Wow, it sounds like the design
thinking principles can be applied to so
many different processes and systems.
And in what you just described it really
underlies that there's a science to it.
It's creative and it's artful but
there's also a science to it and
I personally have been exposed to it and
find it fascinating for
how we can design experiences for people.
So thank you for sharing that.
We recently spoke with GSB professor
Chip Heath about the curse of knowledge,
knowing too much about what we do and
share and how it can lead to
miscommunication and a lack of connection
with those that we're communicating with.
Your focus in your book on widening our
lens strikes me as a way to combat that
course of knowledge and be more
creative and relevant at the same time.
Can you tell us a bit more about what
you mean by widening our lens and
how can we actually do that.
>> Sure, widening your lens.
I use that framing just because as
somebody who's a photographer, I think
a lot about how your perspective is really
altered by not just the equipment that
you're using, but where you're
standing in relation to the subject or
the scene that you're trying to capture.
And in design you want to have a strong
point of view about what you're making,
you want to to understand the needs, you
want to to understand the context and then
you want to say like well I think that
it's going to work best if and then you
really establish that strong point of view
is one of those foundational principles.
But one of the things you have to
recognize is that you don't have the view,
you have a point of view, right?
>> Right.
>> And really understanding like well, how
is someone else going to experience this
product or service that I'm developing?
Or what if I think about what the effect
of launching this thing might be a few
generations into the future?
And so there are all different
ways to stretch your perspective.
Both to be thinking about how
could this be better designed,
how could it be more effective?
How could it be more relevant for
more people and even thinking about, what
are some of the potentially unintended
consequences that could happen as I create
this fantastic popular successful piece of
work, whatever it is that you're doing.
So widening your lens is one of those
core ideas in human centered design.
In that very often you are not
designing for yourself.
>> Yeah.
>> And you kind of have to get out of your
own way to effectively design
with others needs in mind.
And so
that idea of shifting your perspective,
widening your aperture your lens,
is just critically important.
And there are lots of ways to do that.
And some of the practices in creative
acts are great ways to start their
practices around how do you have a very
open ended interview interaction,
how do you try to shadow someone for a day
>> I heard you say two things that I think
are absolutely critical to getting
out of that curse of knowledge and
how design thinking and
being creative can help.
And one is understanding that it is
other focused you talked about human
centered design.
So you're not designing for
yourself you're designing for others.
When you communicate you're
not communicating for
yourself you're communicating for others.
So first taking that perspective and
then the second thing you said which is so
important is to get out of your own way
that we actually make it more difficult
for ourselves and it sounds like some
of the activities in your book and that
are practiced at the D school can really
help people with both parts of that.
focusing in the right place and
then getting out of our own way.
Did I get that right?
>> Yeah that's exactly right.
And we all bring our own life experience,
our own biases our own opinions and
perspectives and so you often need a way
similar to how we talk about deferring
judgment when you're trying
to generate new ideas.
You actually need to set aside those
assumptions that you have, those biases,
those perspectives that you have, to make
sure they are not too influential in your
interpretation or
understanding of what the needs are.
>> Wherever I think about what
we've talked about so far,
part of the design process really
involves introspection and reflection.
I'm curious if you can articulate
why this is so important.
And what are some of
the specific tools and
techniques that you recommend to help
people do this type of self learning?
>> Well, it's interesting that you just
framed up this idea of self learning,
because I often think about design
as a process of learning in general.
So when you're starting out to
design something new whether
it's reimagining the substitute
teaching ecosystem,
like I mentioned our former fellow
Joe Violet did, or something much more
concrete and physical, you're embarking
on a journey of learning, right?
You are starting out with less
understanding and information and insight.
>> And fewer ideas about where you're
going to land the thing that you're
going to create, then you will
ultimately find yourself with.
And just like any other learning process,
understanding what's going well and
what's not going well and
what could be improved.
That is a vital part of really
having ownership over that process.
So we do a lot of work with our students
and other learners around tools for
reflection, thinking about,
what just happened and
was it as productive as effective as
powerful as we hoped that it was?
What can be improved?
And maybe even then some
bigger picture questions.
So I'll give you two examples of
particular practices that we use.
One is an individual practice which
is called what so what now it.
Letizia burritos company RL and
some of her colleagues created and
what they found is that when they ask
students to just kind of generically
reflect in an open ended way on how
class went or what they learned or
what a particular process let's say
they were teaching prototyping that day.
Okay, how did that go,
the students come up with some interesting
things
>> But when they give them a particular
framework like what so what now what,
which is simply the idea that you separate
you disaggregate and distinguish
between those three different buckets.
So what just happened?
Name all the details.
What did it smell like?
What was the feeling that you had?
Specifically what happened?
And then, so what, which is like,
well, what were the implications?
What did that lead to?
What happened as a result?
And now what, which is like,
well, what does that mean?
What does that suggest for the future?
How do you feel about that?
Those bigger introspective questions.
With that particular rubric the
reflections that the students do are of
much higher caliber and
much more powerful as a learning tool as
a self learning tool as you just said.
So that's one great example of
a practice on the personal level.
And then one of my favorites from this
collection is called I like I wish how to.
And that is a practice that we've been
using at the D school from the very
beginning.
And it really is wonderful as a group
to go through experience together.
That could be a day of class that
could be a workshop that could be.
A tough year at your company and
do a group reflection using those prompts.
I like, I wish and how to.
And that is a non-judgmental or
less judgmental way to still be able to
say like, hey, here's what went well.
Here's what I wish for.
And here's some other ideas that are
starting to come up about what we could do
to change things or improve things.
>> Well, I think we have bingo now,
because anybody who knows me and
listens to this podcast knows that, what
so, what now, what is a mantra that I sing
the praises for all the time and
I love how you apply it.
In terms of self learning in terms
of feedback and introspection and
having tools as you've discussed to help
us do that is really really helpful.
Because for many of us it's really hard to
take the time to do that reflection and
having specific tools can help.
In thinking back to all of the various
activities and techniques in your book,
can you identify one that has
really helped you personally?
>> Yeah I mentioned I like I wish
which has been quite important for
me the category that I'll share that
I think has been really useful for
me particularly in a leadership role.
To remember to practice consistently,
is around using those first few minutes
of any meeting or work session,
to set the right tone and to get people
already starting to practice some
of the behaviors that you want to
see come out in the work to be done.
>> Through some kind of warm up activity.
And I have kind of a strong point of
view that like icebreakers are fine, but
usually what I'm doing is not trying
to just get people to break the ice and
know each other a little bit.
I'm actually wanting people to
start to rehearse the same behavior
that we need to then practice as a group.
So the activities that are around.
Building trust with someone.
That's a wonderful warm up to do if
you're going to have a group then
start to launch an interviewing process or
even if you're just going to try
to make a hard decision, right?
That's a really good time
to use that as a team.
Or the activity that's around coming up
with lots of metaphors and similes for
complex problems or topics.
That is a great warm up to use when you
are launching a storytelling session or
you are trying to figure out how you're
going to present your really cool but
kind of esoteric new idea
to a group of people.
So I like to really match the nature
of the warm up with the work at hand.
And if I'm the one who's leading
the class or the workshop,
I'll then be very transparent for folks.
Hey, the reason we started with this is
because it's going to lead right into what
we're doing today as a group.
And I find that that helps people get
like right into the right mindset and
the right kind of skill set for
the work at hand.
>> I find that so refreshing because so
many people do icebreakers just for
the sake of doing an icebreaker in this
notion that the activity you initiate
with can actually serve as a signpost for
what's to come or get people to rehearse
and practice skills that you'll be
developing, I think is really powerful.
And I encourage everybody to think about
when you initiate a meeting a presentation
any kind of collaboration?
How can you start with some kind of
activity that gets people focused and
engaged but also begins working on
the skills you're trying to build?
I really like that idea and
will immediately begin
applying it in the work I do.
Before we end I'd like to ask you the same
three questions I asked everyone who joins
me, are you up for that?
>> Yes.
>> Excellent.
Alright.
Here we go.
Question one.
If you were to capture the best
communication advice you ever received
as a five to seven word presentation
slide title, what would it be?
>> Immediately what comes to minds,
is just a slide that says pause more.
>> Tell me more about that.
I'm going to take a pause
before you answer though.
Okay, go ahead.
Tell me more.
>> I love talking about this topic.
I love talking about this material.
When I get excited about
something I just get on a roll and
often string things together that
deserve more breathing room.
And as a communicator, I am working on
trying to slow down and pause more, right?
silence is such a powerful
tool in multiple dimensions,
whether it's giving someone else
the chance for their brain to catch up,
whether it's for you to slow down and
then be able to observe new things and
take in detail in a way that
you weren't previously.
So I think that my excitement and
enthusiasm sometimes just revs up the
speed and the pace at which I'm talking.
And really, just slowing down and
pausing occasionally can be so helpful.
>> Not only does it help you think and
formulate, but
it also helps the audience as well.
And I am in your camp,
when I get excited, I talk more than less.
Let me ask question number two, who is
a communicator that you admire and why?
>> The first person who jumps to
mind right now is Phoebe Robinson,
who is a comedian and a TV host.
And she's now running a book imprint,
publishing imprint.
I feel like she just has this incredible
facility with language, and she's
constantly inventing words, and yet you
completely understand what she's saying.
And somehow it's like so
much funnier because it's in this sort
of like language of her own invention.
And it's really body and satirical and
it's just just very, very funny.
And I suspect that she is making so
many specific decisions
about her language choice and
her created words.
And I'd love to just get
a peek inside her brain and
understand more about how she
thinks about these things.
>> What a true compliment,
when you want to really understand
somebody's thought process that
leads them to their communication.
Let me ask the final question.
What are the first three ingredients that
go into a successful communication recipe?
>> Maybe the most important
ingredient is caring about the topic.
I think the second one for me is about
distilling the content
into its barest form.
And then for me, I'm often communicating
in a visual medium, as are so many people.
So I think I immediately just leap to
thinking about designing a keynote or
a PowerPoint presentation.
Which so many people have,
as a human race, we have wasted so
much time trying to read size
eight fonts on [LAUGH] a slide.
It's just so sad.
So when I'm thinking about using visuals
to amplify the presentation I'm giving or
the ideas I'm trying to share,
I think about what I'm excited about,
my passion or commitment to the material.
I mean, and this is true even if I'm
giving a budget report in the dean's
office, I want to see some
student faces on that.
I want to always be reminded of the
purpose behind the work that we're doing.
And then think about the simplest
form that I can use,
and the fewest words, and
how much of it can become visual.
So let me go back and
try to boil that down into three
[LAUGH] simple ingredients.
I think it's about interest and
passion for the content,
simplicity, and
bringing things to life in a visual way.
>> I think those are three
very powerful ingredients and
can be very helpful for
all the types of communication that we do.
Well, Sarah, I have to thank you so much.
Your ideas are super practical,
super helpful, and really, really fun.
I've enjoyed our conversation.
I appreciate your insights into design,
creativity, and communication.
And I encourage everyone to get Sarah's
book, Creative Acts for Curious People.
And then you have to
immediately read it and
apply these incredibly useful lessons and
activities.
Thank you for joining us and
thank you for sharing.
>> My pleasure.
Thank you so much for having me, Matt.
[MUSIC]
>> Thanks for joining us for
another episode of Think Fast Talk Smart,
the podcast.
Produced by Stanford University's
Graduate School of Business.
For more information and
episodes, visit gsb.stanford.edu.
Or subscribe to our show
wherever you get your podcasts.
Finally, find us on social
media @Stanford.GSB